we're gonna throw a hat back here on the
show uh reappearing uh it's been a while
though uh the unicorn airs tonight at 9
30 p.m eastern on cbs we've had walter
goggins and rob cordray on to talk about
it and once again
omar miller back here on the show how
you been sir what's up man
oh i've been good you know i've been i
got i got two world championships in the
city of angels life is good i know i
think the last time you were here you
know we looked it up
um because that's what we do because
we're professionals uh it was about a
year ago and you were nervous about the
dodgers nationals
and uh rightfully so as it all turned
out
you know it turns out you knew but yeah
you saw that one coming but
i mean uh this year the lakers dodgers
double dip has got to be
something for you obviously oh it's
delicious it's absolutely delicious and
i'm not even a lakers fan but
the city's been through so much man
earthquakes and fires
obviously the pandemic beings botched
and the whole song and dance
and uh it was clutch for the guys to
come through
so shout out to lebron james and shout
out to the best player in baseball
mookie bets regardless of whatever mvps
they want to give out and this that and
the other
is one key factor that was different
between
last uh three years in this year and
it's a man named mookie betts manning
right field
who beat every team in a different way
it's incredible to watch if you really
know baseball
well i mean yeah we could let's linger
here not only because i just love
talking about mookie betts but my
colleague across the way chris brockman
is a red sox fan who laments his
departure every single day
so um oh mark come on man but i mean i
think you're referring to that throw he
made from the right field foul poll
uh to third base in arizona during uh a
regular season game uh and then
you know uh i know again corey seeger
was the mvp of the world series and
rightfully so
but that that final game of the world
series
where betts was the one who immediately
made the rey's pay for taking snell out
of the game
by setting up two runners in scoring
position uh allowing the
tying run to score because of a wild
pitch and then
uh scoring on a hot smash to first might
be the only guy on the team who've been
able to do that
pretty much well here's the thing and i
you know i know i'm here to talk about
the unicorn but i don't know
whenever i get to that i got to talk
bell yeah go for it and
let me tell you the truth of the matter
is if you watch
in between the game in between the stat
lines
mookie best wins you every game and it's
not just the throw from right field
it's the leaping catches that he makes
it's the positioning where he is and the
jumps he gets on the baseball
it's helping cody bellinger out at
center field it's running the bases
properly because it's not all about
speed
that's why he's able to score from third
because he gets the proper secondary
lead
he works counts he then in turn from
working counts
makes corey seeger gets pitched pitches
that he wouldn't have gotten
the guy affects change in every single
way that you can
some of it shows up in the box fort a
lot of it doesn't and you kind of have
to have a trained eye to see
how he's affecting the game and
obviously yeah and obviously you as a
dodger fan would
know omar that um very rarely do you sit
in a rocking chair from the eighth
inning on you know with the bullpen
um but the fact that he no i i don't
mean
i mean that seriously that the bullpen
uh i know aureus was
clutch uh in many ways but the fact that
betts provided the insurance run in that
game six with a solo shot on top of
everything that we're talking about
he's yeah i'm i'm totally with you man i
mean that he
and we got him for a dozen years can you
believe it
brock but shaking his head over there
you're bad man you guys can't let the
best player in baseball walk you insane
he already won you
world series maybe even two yeah omar
i'm aware of that one
i'm aware i know what happened
but thank you from beantown to ours now
we're titled i'm here to help yeah i
know
and and it was neat to see kershaw right
uh celebrating like that
omar i'm so happy for that guy right i'm
so happy for him
he's such a good person everybody that
you know interacts with him you can see
it and feel it from the word go
and you know for him to be constantly
stigma as though he wasn't clutch
and honestly he pitched you two big
games in this world series
and he the the guy has
had to shoulder the team for so long for
him to finally
get some help and to not have his
pictures being you know tipped by
electronics and and bs
it's great for this dude to now get to
celebrate so he can take his rightful
place
in generational you know celebration
because he's a once-in-a-generation
pitcher
omar miller here on the rich eisen show
and in terms of your previous work we
will get to the unicorn in a second
although i guess we are talking about a
unicorn in uh in mookie bets right now
um is that that in terms of
people you've worked with in your career
um
who's been the mookie bets who's like
perfect at everything
that you've worked with oh wow that's a
tough one
well i got i've got some choices for you
just off the top line
here okay so you've been an eight mile
so obviously you've been around
marshall mathers you've been around
eminem right um
ballers you've been around the rock and
then my choice
you've been around david caruso csi
miami
right omar you know what i'm saying yeah
what do you think yeah
these are if if we're gonna go through
those three i haven't heard
either caruso or dwayne drop a hot 16.
so you probably have to lean on marshall
if we're talking about somebody who can
do it all
yes yes i i got a i got a wild card in
there for you
please because in all honesty
benicio del toro can do it all man dude
can do comedy i've worked with him on
the film called things we lost
in the fire okay and he can do it all
and and
and and keeping it super 100 it might be
the guy i work with every day now in
walton goggins
i love that guy because yes you can see
him be one way on the unicorn
he's another way on the righteous
gemstones he's a serial killer on the
justified
you know he's he played the uh uh uh
transgendered woman on sons of anarchy
you have
nothing but nothing but options this
guy's really talented i i feel the
pretty good fantasy entertainment yes
yes you do yes you do and we had walton
here as well and i uh
my kid went against his kid in a uh in a
pony baseball
league game a couple years ago here in
los angeles he's just a regular dude too
just a dad
you know i mean just in real life too i
mean that's not a bad choice
omar that's not a bad choice he's a
sleeper so you'll get them you'll get
them for cheap
but they'll that's in your daily fantasy
that's in your daily fantasy right
exactly that's in your daily unicorn
fantasy fantastic
keeper league we got to go with a
younger guy you know
we got to get some youth if we're doing
a keeper fantasy i love it
uh so the unicorn the unicorn is back
tonight right so these are all
uh you shot these during the pandemic
right is that when you did as well so
these are all new
oh man we're shooting them now shooting
them now right
okay so you're shooting these now okay
yeah and it's and it's rough the copic
protocol was real man
i tell you i go to the grocery store i
go here i go there and people are on my
helmet about having something new to
watch
right makes me feel like a version of an
essential worker
because everybody's worn out their
netflix queue their amazon q
and they're looking for new and we got
it for you on the unicorn
so it shows them really well received um
they did a really smart thing and put
the first season available to binge on
uh
netflix and now the new season is
available only on cbs
and cbs all access and you know
we're dealing our show's super relevant
now even more so than before
because we're dealing with grief and
loss and moving forward in your life
with hope and optimism
uh be a community via the family that
you choose which are your friends
and with the pandemic and all of the
crisis that are going on financially in
every other way
it's extremely relevant to help people
deal
it's a neat show on cbs tonight uh at 9
30 p.m eastern time season two premiered
last thursday so we're off and running
in that second season
and then uh i've you know i'm reading uh
the card that uh
uh that's been placed in front of me
about everything else that's going on
with you
omar um i was unaware that there's a
lego star wars holiday special coming up
on disney plus
um that's on right now it's out now it's
out right now it's out i'm all in i
didn't i did not know that i got to get
on that with my kids we got to we got to
get on that that's fantastic
let me know what you think people so far
this has been really really well
received
i don't know this voiceover thing is new
to me but they've welcomed me with open
arms and now i'm doing it you know
teenage mutant ninja turtle movie for
netflix we're doing this thing
got some other stuff up my sleeve it's
you know it's been a really
tough year and then it's been a really
blessed year in other ways
i try to look at the positives i'll get
on that my kids love lego star wars and
then uh
do i need to um have my head on a swivel
and see your footsteps coming that you
and your brother are having what's
called an unfair and partial sports
podcast called the ozone do i have to
do i have to worry about you completely
personal now we're not on your level
rich
okay we're having a good time you know
we're we're talking about mookie bets
we called him the best player in
baseball before he won this last
championship we talk a lot of boxing and
we're having a good time and you're
welcome to come on our podcast
time and then you know you're you're our
high fantasy draft when it comes to gaff
i appreciate that i appreciate that i
would love to uh return the favor and do
a home and home although uh as we uh we
wrap up this conversation on behalf of
my colleague
uh chris brockman who is uh stinging
from all of this
uh mookie betts talk um you know uh the
rich eisen show staff has found several
photographs of you
omar wearing other hats than just a
dodger cap
uh we have a shot of you in a yankee lid
um a detroit lid a
braves lid these are all from uh red
carpets they appear
also it appears you're wearing a full
washington nationals uniform that
that reeks of all-star game material
that's all started that was celebrated
that was for the wounded warriors okay
so that's for a cause what about the
other what about the other lids that
you're wearing uh casually in in real
life
are you forgetting you're true blue
what's going on it's fashion it's
fashion it's design hold on a second
don't question my my loyalty to the
dodgers
i have a story for that the truth of the
matter is my brother
who's my podcast uh uh co-host yes terry
miller was drafted by the dodgers and
done dirty by the organization
way on back in the early 90s so i had a
bone to pick with them
and what what happened was we actually
started working with don mattingly when
he was the head coach of the dodgers
and the dodgers foundation and thus the
kershaw foundation yes and that's what
brought me around
okay so i'll be back home so
you and the braves lid and the and the
yankee lid which you know i appreciate
and the the detroit tiger lid that's for
fashion that's just like because it
matched or it made you feel good about
what you were
as an ensemble on the red carpets that
we see this
website detroit lit a lot of times that
was a that was a nod to eight mile which
uh you know
springboarded my career correct so i i
definitely i owe the city of detroit a
lot
all right you know detroit stand up the
bravos
when i was a kid i used to to love john
smoltz and watching ron gant
out there okay but uh okay you know but
the these are fashion choices you show
me at the games
show me front row waving the dodger flag
with kareem at the world series
you know that's that's what you need to
focus on hold on a second hold on a
second kareem as an abdul jabbar is that
who you're dropping
the captain as in as in the all-time
leading scorer as in the greatest
basketball player of all time
that's a very large name to just drop on
the way out the door omar that's
important listen
you tried to come at me rich
always enjoy our chat omar thanks for
having uh the the moment to call in here
i'm
more than happy to appear in your pod
with your brother and we'll be watching
the unicorn
on cbs uh tonight and every thursday at
9 00 30 eastern time thanks for the call
all right fellas have a good one you got
it that's uh omar miller at
omar benson miller on instagram omar
miller on twitter always fun talking to
omar